[Music]  as the waimakariri district's population  grows and more people choose to walk and  cycle we need to ensure our walking and  cycling networks are safe and connect  people to where they need to go  safe and connected walking and cycling  networks also give people more choice  about how they travel  [Music]  walking and cycling can help to reduce  emissions and encourage healthier  lifestyles  several of our towns are connected and  we now have a safe cycle link between  waimakiri and christchurch  but there is still work to be done  to cater for increased demand on our  transport network we have identified new  connections throughout the district as  part of a walking and cycling network  plan  we'd love to hear what you think  learn more and have your say at  waimakariri dot govt dot nz forward  slash let's talk